[Musique]
parité nom féminin signifiant égalité du
nombre la parité a longemps été
l'arlaisienne de la politique on sait
qu'elle existe dans la loi mais on ne
l'a jamais vraiment vu dans la réalité
la parité électorale a pourtant fait
l'objet d'une loi constitutionnelle en
99 et on ne rigole pas avec les lois
constitutionnelles enfin normalement
parce que dans les fait la parité c'est
quand même un peu carnaval au point
qu'il a fallu une deuxème loi en 2000
pour obliger les partis politiques
a présenté autant d'hommes que de femmes
dans tous les scrutins de liste à partir
de 3500 habitants notamment pour les
municipales mais les partis politiques
généralement dirigés par des hommes sont
de grands adolescents tout ce qui est
obligatoire va directement sous le tapis
de toute façon c'est pas eux qui font le
ménage ben oui ils font de la politique
madame c'est cela oui alors rebelote
2007 nouvelle loi certains l'ont appelé
la loi shabadabada terminer les bêtises
dans les communes de plus de 3500
habitants on alterne un candidat et une
candidate et toute liste ne respectant
pas cette alternance dehors mais pour
les municipales de 2014 le scrutin de
liste s'applique désormais à partir de
1000 habitants et non plus de 3500
conséquence les communes de plus de 1000
habitants sont soumis à cette obligation
de parité un homme une femme un homme
une femme ou une femme un homme une
femme un homme il y a pas de raison tout
ça pour dire mesdames qu'il va falloir
leur montrer où se trouve l'aspirateur
avant que vous ne partiez pour le
conseil municipal M